hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's a
couple Game of Thrones clips to play a
couple announcement to uses that dropped
and they're starting to build a case
about Jon Snow vs sunset so I'll explain
what's going on
[Music]
so let's start with the important stuff
first the teaser for the concert is is
basically like the person who composes
music for Game of Thrones he's totally
amazing music is one of the most
important things about this show they're
doing like a big live concert at the
Hollywood Palladium next Monday as I'm
posting this August 8th that starts at
11:30 a.m. the composer as well as Isaac
Hempstead right are going to be there
doing a Q&A as well and they're making a
special announcement about an expansion
they're calling it an expansion to the
game of Thrones universe so because
that's so general like everyone's like
what the hell does that mean are they
announcing a theme park or something
like that what I think is going on is
that they're gonna announce like a
permanent installment for the Hall of
faces or something of that nature or
something somewhat Museum related but I
don't think they're gonna have like a
Game of Thrones theme park and they
haven't really started production of the
new season yet so they might talk about
Season seven during the Q&A but I don't
think the HBO is officially announcing
anything for Season seven but whatever
they end up talking about I'll totally
do a video for it that's gonna happen
next Monday if you do live near Los
Angeles you could try to go to that live
concert but moving to Jon Snow vs. Sansa
season 7 stuff so they've they've been
hyping this a little bit like sophie
turner was hyping it a little bit at
comic-con i wasn't taking it too
seriously til i saw some more recent
videos they post it so i'm gonna play
this here there's just like a funny
parody for the election stuff that's
happening in the so like you can see
that they have about a month left before
they close the polls but currently
leading or Daenerys Targaryen with her
running mate Tyrion Lannister as you'd
probably imagine Tyrion probably one of
the best people for ruling but then as
if to height Jon Snow vs. Sansa like you
see Jon Snow with the little bear on the
same ticket which i think is pretty
adorable but then you have Littlefinger
and sanso on the same ticket so like
even HBO is hyping up Jon Snow vs. Sansa
and in the way sophie Turner talked
about him she's irritated with Jon
doesn't think that he's right to rule
and there's this clip where she talks
about how you know like her mother grew
up hating Jon Snow because she thought
that he was the product of an affair
with Ned Stark and another woman so now
I'm gonna play that Thrones is really at
the heart of it about dysfunctional
families
there's always been tension between them
because since they were little dancers
always looked up to her mother and
always just taken on her mother's views
of everything you know her mother really
didn't like John because of whole affair
thing doesn't mean that they don't love
each other but it's just you know
typical sibling tension we need to trust
each other we can't fire a war amongst
ourselves with so many enemies now
[Music]
I think John is oblivious he hasn't
actually learned his lesson from trying
to pay attention to what she's feeling
he says he has but he's asking her to
trust him
he's not listening and watching an
observing car I think that could be a
real problem for him I don't care if
he's a bastard that starts blood runs
through his veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day Jonah's the right man for the
job we all want a leader who's gonna be
decent and honorable and I think he's
definitely entitled to be running
Winterfell
although Sansa might have a problem with
her I fear her relationship with Jon
Snow
I think is an indication of what's going
to come and I'm not sure it's gonna be
pretty
the king in the north he's named king in
the Northland she kind of gets no credit
for it John doesn't acknowledge
everything his sister has done for him
after all that we've been through and
it's not that she's looking for praise
or anything she did it because she wants
revenge and also because she wants her
home back John be so naive so Sansa is
just a little bit agitated it is real so
you watch something like that and one
you think wow I really hate Sansa and I
kind of hate Catelyn a little bit too
now for hating Jon Snow so much it's not
his fault that he's a bastard but number
two it also tells you what the drama is
going to be in the north south of the
wall now north of the wall we still have
brand versus the night's king but we
just named Jon Snow king of the north so
Littlefinger looks like he's wasting no
time in plotting on how to get his hooks
into Sansa and twist her against Jon
Snow because as a stark a lot of the
north will still rally behind her so
it's very possible if left to his own
devices he could create another civil
war in the north which would be like the
worst possible thing that could happen
especially with the Nights king's army
trying to make its way south of the wall
and Daenerys getting ready to take
King's Landing
so the ray of hope I think is that
regardless of you know what drama there
is in the north bran will resurface
before it actually comes to a real Civil
War and we'll explain what's going on
with Jon Snow his parentage and his role
in the war to come so they'll both back
off a little bit you can see why it
would merit fewer episodes just because
they wouldn't want to drag out that
drama of Jon Snow vs. Sansa next year
like clearly they have to build to a
breaking point bran has to appear to
explain to them then they have to chill
out so if you were to drag that out
across ten episodes it would be almost
unbearable just because everyone already
knows where the story is going so until
the White Walkers show up I feel like
Jon Snow and sonses story is the one
that's in most danger of being turned
into filler if they're not careful
because it sounds like they're pushing
off White Walkers making it south of the
wall at least till the end of season
seven maybe beginning of season eight
just so they can spend that whole final
season in just like crazy pitch battle
every single episode so you have
Daenerys versus Cersei that's going to
be a lot of fun to watch that'll be
really entertaining just dragons laying
to everything I will be very surprised
if Cersei doesn't find a little more
wildfire to use on Daenerys as troops
that would probably be the most
effective thing she could do and she
could answer the question as to whether
or not Daenerys is also immune to
wildfire which I feel like she would be
well let me know in the comments what do
you think about the show pushing John
snow versus Sansa and how long do you
think they'll drag that out till they
come to their senses and they learn
about Jon Snow's true origin because
remember Jon Snow doesn't know anything
about what bran saw yet he has to tell
him first
Sansa doesn't know either she still
thinks that he's a bastard and it sounds
like she might even still Harbor some
some like deep-seated resentment against
him like the low-grade type of
resentment the Catelyn held for him
which is actually very important to Jon
Snow's character development but we can
talk more about Jon Snow's character
development in another video so giveaway
time congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner
Renzo Pacheco you win a $20 Amazon gift
card just be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel so I get
your contact details so big announcement
coming on Monday be sure to subscribe to
get that and if there's any other bonus
videos you guys want me to do this
weekend just let me know in the comments
so while you guys wait for my next video
to post you can click here for my season
7 teaser trailer and you can click here
for all my other comic-con trailer
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight